terrad v mahomes was one of
one two three four match-ups going into
week two
of black starting quarterbacks uh and
there's a total i believe of ten
black starting quarterbacks in the nfl
right now
um what does that mean to you in 2020
you know we talk a lot about the fact
that there are so few
head coaches uh both in the nfl and for
that matter in the nba not to mention
college sports across the board
so few black head coaches black
ownership is still the
uh uncharted frontier for the most part
uh
yeah what does that mean to you have
that number uh 10 black quarterbacks
well i i it's significant it means
it means a lot to me and i'm just gonna
i'm gonna tell you why uh
and where i'm gonna tell you why and i'm
gonna tell you where i wanna see it go
now i remember like yesterday i was
watching nightline now what was i doing
up there late i don't know but i was
watching nightline
when al campanis
uh told ted koppel that blacks do not
he said it blacks do not have the
necessities to be managers and major
league baseball
you just said it flat out i'm like yo
i'm a baseball fan what do you mean
you don't have necessities look i could
probably manage a baseball team i'm not
oh come on
if you love the game and you got some
intelligence and you and you can lead
people
of course you have the necessities and
so ted koppel went back at him said well
excuse me mr campanis did you just say
what i thought you said
he did campanis was fired disgraced
but the industry didn't catch up to it
the industry still didn't
didn't right that wrong and so it is
still a thing
black managers in baseball is still a
thing
uh now you talk about black quarterbacks
when doug williams let the washington
football
team to a victory in the super bowl over
the broncos
it was a huge thing in the black
community
i was not a washington fan but i was a
doug williams fan because that meant a
lot to me i had heard
all the excuses i heard all these
comments and all the shade
thrown at black quarterbacks over the
years and so to see him in that position
fill me with a great deal of pride so
where what does it mean to me now
michael smith
i'm glad that a lot of people
coming up you know teenagers might be
watching this saying hey what's the big
deal
what's the big deal i've seen lots of
black quarterbacks you know
i've seen great black quarterbacks i've
seen backups
uh i've seen journeyman like all over
it's not a big deal
well i'm glad that quarterbacks are
being entrusted
to just be like everybody else
like you don't say about white
quarterbacks can you leave my franchise
can you be my franchise secret no it's
like hey you're a quarterback
you happen to be white we're gonna you
gotta play the position i'm glad the
same thing is happening
for those quarterbacks but what here's
the next step i want to see it happen
in ownership general managers
and coaching is still a problem it's
still
a problem when it comes to coaches we've
seen black coaches
ownership is a wealth ownership is a
wealth issue and without ownership
general manager and front office my
general manager is
that's an extension of ownership that's
an extension of ownership
um because you know and on that on that
note i'll
have a quick tangent a lot of people you
know talk about colin kaepernick and i i
long
ago stop being upset that colin
kaepernick isn't
playing as much as i'm upset that
the dynamic of nfl ownership is as such
they can
lock out you know colin kaepernick that
they can
effectively in his career because there
are no owners that are willing to
you know uh sign him and deal with what
they think would be the backlash from it
um but going in terms of coaches
there's still there's still not enough
coaches black coaches on the offensive
side of the ball
um because a lot of times when owners
are looking and especially in this day
and age owners are looking for head
coaches they look to the offensive side
of the ball
and that pipeline for some reason seems
to be a little clogged when it comes to
quarterback coaches and play callers
somebody told me this recently too when
it comes to um
black general managers they get uh they
get elevated they don't get hired
and uh and the distinction being a lot
of times they rise through the ranks of
the organization as opposed to being
brought from outside the organization
which comes with a different level of uh
identification and commitment
but going back to quarterback so for a
second it's not just
that there are 10 black quarterbacks
it's that they're among the best
quarterbacks by and large were you
talking about my holmes
lamar jackson the last two mvps we just
started off the show talking about maybe
the best quarterback right now is
russell wilson
uh deshawn watson cam newton's having a
renaissance in new england
kyla murray looks like he'll be the next
second year quarterback to take a huge
leap
dak prescott made history yesterday
throwing for 400 yards and rushing for
three touchdowns
so it's not just that there are black
quarterbacks populating the league
not just their black starting
quarterbacks but they're excelling
and really ushering in a quarterback
revolution because the style of play
also has a lot to do with it a style of
play traditionally
uh reserved if you will or traditionally
associated with black quarterbacks
is now the dominant style of play for
nfl quarterbacks i'm talking about dual
threats
uh it's it's more much more acceptable
or much more
popular shall we say than it used to be
where
a lot of times you know a running
quarterback would be frowned upon you
have to win from the pocket well you
know running quarterbacks are now
the norm shout out to josh allen by the
way uh up in buffalo yeah holding it
down
but the thing i do want to say about
that though is but we're not we're not
so far removed it's not i don't know
that we're beyond
black quarterback yet because it wasn't
that long ago
when hall of fame general manager bill
polian was suggesting that lamar jackson
changed positions after a heisman trophy
uh in a prolific career at louisville it
wasn't that long ago and again i don't
want to i don't want to
you know talk about just trolls on
twitter or idiots but it wasn't that
long ago where i think a superintendent
in houston
questioned desean watson's intelligence
for a decision he made at the end of the
game so i i think we're
i think we're past the point of looking
at a quarterback and necessarily
judging him strictly by the color of his
skin up but
because now if you do that you get
called on it you know
you get you know people are coming after
you if you dare subscribe to
uh racist or dis discriminatory
uh stereotypes or tropes but we also
know that
now when we're talking about being the
face of a league that comes with a whole
another set of issues because you know
guys like deshawn
and patrick mahomes of course took part
in the in the black lives matter video
in the off season now that next frontier
at least as a black quarterback is okay
are you seen uh as somebody who can
carry the league from a brand and from a
reputation and from uh from a
uh you know in the face of the league
standpoint
and it seems like though those guys are
up for it and we'll see how if society
is right but he's
truly ready to blaze bright quarterbacks
in that way well see that
that's that's that's what part of my
problem is uh mike and it's part of the
wrestling that i have that's why i was
making all these faces
uh when you were talking you you you're
talking well okay you make a lot of
sense
but i'm just imagining some of the
things that
that you're saying and why it has to be
this case be this way
so that's why we're not far we're not so
far
beyond it we're not to the point where
we should be all right
if i'm a quarterback i'm black
don't ask me if i can lead your
community
uh your community team i'm great in pr
i'm great in this i'm doing that no i'm
a quarterback we don't say that about
all quarterbacks hey this guy is going
to be
uh he's going to lead your state he's
going to be the governor
he's going to do all these wonderful
things and he's going to be exceptional
the best quarterback you've ever seen no
what you're saying is he's good enough
to play the position we're going to hand
a position to him
and we're going to try to build a good
team around them like why why do we need
this
black exceptionalism just to have an
opportunity
to have to play that position and so
yeah
if if you go back a little bit that's
why exclusionary practices
are just so maddening uh whether we're
talking about black people whether we
talk about women
we're talking about anybody who has been
shut out or anybody who has been
pushed back where they belong
okay if you go back to mlb and jackie
robinson
breaking the color line uh was it a
surprise
like people are like want to say oh
that's awesome that's awesome like we
have a black player in baseball and he's
good he's a rookie of the year and he's
an mvp
of course nobody like we didn't think
we weren't good enough you did yeah
it's not a surprise that jackie robinson
was an mvp
and larry larry dobey and don nukem and
roy campanella
and all these people all these talented
players
and hank aaron and and on and on that's
not a surprise to me so
when you say hey look at these black
quarterbacks they're some of the best in
the league
no kidding that's the that's the problem
the problem is that we're looking at it
like oh wow they can play we know that
we know they could play why didn't you
know that and it's funny that you
mentioned bill polian
sure he got caught on it but what
organization drafted lamar jackson
at number 32 one of the first
organizations to have
a black general manager the baltimore
ravens and ozzie newsome
is that a coincidence
probably not yeah yeah
so we still we we got a level to get to
yeah definitely got a long way to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports